every time you use your credit card a
whole series of behind-the-scenes steps
and fees kicks in so you can get
but this system has been getting more
and more expensive okay your total will
be 14.85 please this 15 lunch probably
cost the shop around 37 to 46 cents in
various fees
it adds up and it's why this place
prefers cash we have the cash sign so
that we don't have to pay fees
we save money we save money on every
sale some businesses are even starting
to implement surcharges adding around
three percent to your bill if you pay by
credit card
and now congress is getting involved
swipe fees just aren't annoying to the
retailers
they're anti-competitive here's how the
credit card fee system works and what
congress is trying to change
your credit card involves two main
companies your bank which loans you the
money and the card network that handles
the transaction like visa or mastercard
those two companies handle the most
credit card transactions in the us
when you use your credit card the
transaction runs through a store's
processing system through the credit
cards network to your cards bank and
there are fees throughout these steps
the processing systems fee is generally
fairly low around one-tenth of a percent
of the total purchase there's a large
market the merchant can choose from
which can keep this cost down then
there's the credit card's network fee
around a quarter of a percent and the
largest fee of the system also happens
here the interchange fee it's usually
around two to three percent
it's set by the card networks but it's
paid to your bank that issued your
credit card you get rewards for every
purchase everything essentially that fee
helps to fund the rewards that we all
get when we use our credit cards earn
five percent on travel purchased through
chase with chase freedom unlimited cash
back credit cards or credit cards with
miles for travel benefits
someone's paying for that it can be only
a few cents or maybe a few dollars but
then think about how much that adds up
when you take into account all
transactions being made
merchants paid banks and other credit
card issuers interchange fees set by
visa and mastercard roughly 55 billion
just last year
interchange fees vary by card generally
a higher rewards card will come with a
higher interchange fee and businesses
have little control over this they can't
choose to not accept a high rewards card
because of the fees if they want to
accept any of a network's credit cards
they have to accept all of that
network's credit cards in the end what
ends up playing out is that because the
interchange fees are hefty merchants
kind of build that in to the sticker
prices that we all see in many cases
regardless of how we pay so the cash
shopper and the credit card shopper are
often paying the same price but the
credit card shoppers getting the rewards
if a credit card network raises fees
which they did on many purchases this
year businesses have few choices it's
these rising fees that has congress
wanting the credit card system to look
more like the debit card system when you
use your debit card the transaction
looks similar it runs through the source
processor through a card network to your
bank but in 2010 congress passed the
durbin amendment that same durbin
it lowered and set a cap on the
interchange fees that card networks
could set for many banks and it made
banks enable a second network that
merchants could use instead of the card
network that's on the front of your card
so the idea here is merchants should
have the choice of being able to choose
between the more affordable of the
networks so if sending the transaction
over the network that's not visa or
mastercard is cheaper for the merchant
then why shouldn't be able to do that so
it was essentially meant to inject
competition into the debit card space
while also enabling for lower costs
potentially for merchants
and that's what a democrat and
republican senator want to do to the
credit system their bill isn't imposing
a cap on the fees but it would require
larger banks that use visa or mastercard
networks to enable a second network to
make it competitive like the debit
system which should lower fees banks and
credit card companies aren't thrilled
about it there's a potential ripple
effect here if the banks are receiving
lower interchange fees than they
currently are and interchange fees are
funding credit card rewards programs
what would happen to those rewards
programs banks are concerned that this
legislation would limit the amount of
rewards they could offer and the
networks also argue their fees go
towards things like network security and
innovation merchants especially small
businesses are concerned that the
increasing fees are becoming too much on
top of already rising prices there are
two sides to this argument credit cards
incentivize people to spend more than
they otherwise would credit cards result
in more sales than merchants would
otherwise get and there are also costs
associated with not accepting credit
cards like if you're a cash only
business being concerned about cash
theft
and other issues on the other side the
merchant industry is saying yeah but our
costs continue to rise as credit cards
become more and more common for
consumers to use when they're shopping
and fees increase businesses have few
options to offset these rising fees so
more and more places are passing them
along to consumers
so if the price to use credit cards
continues to go up so might your lunch
thank you so much enjoy your chicken
part thank you
have a good day